[Music]
it doesn't matter who your sister is or
who your family member is or who
whatever your relationship is with
something has caused you pain or this is
your experience nothing should diminish
your experience it's like
my whole life i kind of felt like i
didn't matter
so it's like i just wish
that mattered
jamie lynn spears sobs talking about
living in brittany's shadow i'm jenny
directo for entertainment tonight
let's get into it the spears family feud
reached new heights today after jamie
lynn's tell-all memoir dropped
i just kind of learned to stay out of
the way you know okay okay stand away
and two i was so proud of her i was like
i know how hard she worked and i admired
her jamie also revealed her pain when
britney and justin timberlake broke up i
was so sad i don't really know why i was
so sad but i was because like
i think everybody thought it was forever
i remember him fondly because that was
like probably like one of the best times
in my whole family's life you know
things were good and we were
experiencing the good side of things
seeing like how heartbreaking it must
have been for my sister when crimea
river came out i mean like don't get me
wrong like that's a way to watch your
solo career though hey that's a way to
do it but i felt really sad jamie lynn's
emotional sit-down on the call her daddy
podcast is just the latest in the drama
between the sisters as today brent went
on a mini posting spree showing off her
love of trees and this
i'm here to help you but you need to
give me the tools
a skit acting out a therapy session i
think i had too much to eat with my
hamburger britt has called jamie lynn a
quote scum person and accused her of
stooping to a new low quote with these
crazy lies for the hollywood books and
things i should have said out now jamie
lynn describes a major fight with
brittany while the family was
quarantining together in louisiana
brittany became enraged about something
trivial she came at me screaming and
getting in my face while i was holding
ivy who was only 15 months at the time
despite my best efforts britney
continued on the attack to the point
maddie had to get in between us trying
to protect her little sister until my
parents finally got brittany to retreat
i decided then and there no more
i couldn't
be responsible for everything that
happened
around her and also be authentic to
myself it is hard and i'm scared and i'm
all of those things
but
i have to do this
jamie lynn who is now facing heavy
criticism and even threats from britney
fans told e.t she's just sharing her
truth and that she loves her sister we
do have the same parents and that very
much makes us sisters and i love and
support my sister and i respect her
healing process and however she has to
work through things i think that it's a
healing process that i know that i'm
working through i can't speak for anyone
else because
each of us are in this family and we all
are dealing with things individually and
from our own
point of view so i think we have to
respect each other's process as we go
through it but it's in real time
[Music]